Sasson screed valhalla somehow being a
Viking is gonna involve being stealthy
don't know how that's gonna be possible
but it's a cinematic trailer and I feel
like Assassin's Creed always got ret
cinematic trailers before we do that
we're gonna be doing a livestream a
little bit later today probably around
5:30 p.m. Pacific Standard Time that is
requested from our top contributor at
our live streams Anissa Olivia happy
birthday to you my dear wanna shout her
out and another person who times a lot
or live games want to shut him out again
really quick geared towards Inc you
might have seen the video where I unbox
these and you put together John's
getting his own pair of a different kind
of shoes apparently I don't know what
they are I got the shoes right here
there's a photo on screen of some better
or better looking ones
ask them to customize one shoe to be
Joker Arthur flick another wannabe Heath
Ledger wanted to shout him out again
since it's in the month go to his
Instagram follow him today you can order
your own customized shoes as well is
tell him the design and he could put it
together for the right press so happy
birthday you Nitsa and thank you again
geared towards ink now Assassin's Creed
law
[Music]
they are heartless
[Music]
[Music]
English
[Music]
that's like an HBO show
[Music]
[Music]
whoa-oh-oh
there's a rule oh dude
[Music]
I love this cat a violence
oh there you are
damn Jesus oh oh
fake-out oh I really get a lot of the
Assassin's Creed elements in here it's
just like a badass Viking the most
geared towards badass ever since Viking
gonna do any parkour of any sort yes
dive deep off a high tower into a bale
of hay are you gonna get to read
factoids about history the one thing
with this quarantine situation that's
been great it's allowed me to catch up
on some video games beat spider-man ps4
in the past couple weeks I'd begun war
so especially going for this very
animalistic type of brutal fighting
style shouting out Odin this is like the
right trailer for me to follow right
after finishing god of war oh yeah love
the brutality tip towards it and it goes
that same Mandy the cinematic trailers
for Assassin's Creed are always so damn
beautiful you know some of the best
video game cinematic trailers are always
with Assassin's Creed it's funny because
I remember there was a time where it
seemed like there was an assassin's
Creed game coming out like two to three
times a year yeah that way and then when
this came out on IGN today it's thinking
II know it's crazy they were like an MCU
movie over your ziering about them all
the time and actually I saw on Netflix
that the last Kingdom is trending it's
like in the top five somewhere there now
I don't know if they decided to release
this trailer today because the last
Kingdom is doing so well right now a
Netflix [ __ ] is the last Kingdom doing
so well today because of this trailer
either way this looks like the last
Kingdom it looks badass and this seems
well timed because like Vikings the show
is really popular Thor's obviously a
worldwide sensation town this caught me
in the interesting way that you know we
said there's not a lot of like SAS and
Creed earmarks in this trailer but what
I did find curious and what I did like
were those
middle portions where they're talking
about how barbaric and terrible the
Vikings are and then they're showing the
reality like the visual doesn't match
what the King guy is talking about
basically so you have I love that one
shot where it looks like they're doing
some kind of battle and this guy's gonna
strike down a bunch of kids but then the
saturation of the colors changes and it
shows that they're just playing together
they do have like an actual society that
isn't only based on pillaging and you
know causing havoc on other people even
when they just let the like woman and
child run by so it makes me wonder if
maybe we'll get a different perspective
on the Vikings in not the same kind of
like oh here is the famous building
press triangle to read about it way but
maybe we'll get a different look into
the Viking history from their
perspective or something yeah there were
really good people they were really the
kind-hearted Souls that's right
everybody else was evil they were the
ones who were pure Glen Lee yeah and
then the last level is just gonna be
aggressive cuddling once you've trained
the world I mean kind of going off of
what you were saying
normally I feel like not all mediums but
I feel like in a lot of mediums the
Vikings are usually portrayed as the bad
guys the ruthless savage animalistic
creatures who have no boundaries or true
morals and they're they're always viewed
as sort of the main threat it's cool to
get it from their perspective in the
sense of they're the ones you're rooting
for who look like the underdogs in the
situation like to have the reverse of it
when they're on the boats and then the
fire arrows are coming down and then
when they're on the field like him
battling that one guy with the crazy
armor it was like Mountain yes like the
mountain in the Hound going toe-to-toe
with each other yeah I love a good fake
gunner I think it's a pretty traditional
trailer I all things considered there's
nothing really here that reeks of unique
storytelling per se I think it's cool
that for their first show they really
focused in on making it just you know
like pure Viking esque
and not really the Assassin's Creed isms
to it although I would be curious to see
a gameplay trailer to see like what
earmarks of Assassin's Creed are there
especially because like the things that
you associated with this ass Esprit
don't really seem to be present here is
that even with our main character like
my mind just keeps going to the park or
park how's this guy gonna do bar I'm
gonna take place just in one battle like
this or are you gonna have places to
sneak around it
yeah there's stealthy elements where's
that at yeah that doesn't really seem in
play but then there are other cinematic
trailers from assassin's creed that
don't hone in on the stealth or the
parkour elements either but with all
that being said I don't really know jack
about accurate history who he comes to
Vikings and all that everything I'm
talking about is based off of movies and
Joe time to read Norse mythology I
actually don't know like what is really
accurate about depiction here but it
looks like a lot of movies and shows
that I've always thought to be really
cool to look at especially Valhalla
Rising oh yeah necklace when you're
effin and Mads Mikkelsen Hannibal on the
red show guys what do you think of this
Assassin's Creed Valhalla trailer or
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
for the real rejects click the
notification bell keep a look out for
our live stream coming out later today
catch ya see ya thanks for being here
you